something very strange is happening in
Washington DC it's worrying lots of
people
for the first time in U.S history three
military services are operating without
a senate confirmed Chief in charge but
that is not the strangest part the
strangest part is the reason why
Republicans are wielding the power the
people gave them
Senator Tommy tupperville is
single-handedly holding up more than 300
of Joe Biden's senior officer
nominations including the three Joint
Chiefs the liberal journalists are
wringing their hands and clutching their
pearls they're accusing senator
tuberville of weakening our military
but the Liberals at the Pentagon could
end the standoff tomorrow because the
Liberals at the Pentagon are the ones
who started it last October by ramming
through a new policy that pays military
service members to travel out of state
to kill their babies through abortion
that policy was never passed into law by
congress the people never voted for it
it's obviously not a right guaranteed by
the Constitution the whole reason the
Liberals at the Pentagon passed this
policy was because they were angry over
the Supreme Court's decision in the
Dobbs case
which overruled rovie Wade and struck
down the fictional constitutional right
to abortion the whole point of the
military is to protect Americans not to
pay soldiers to kill the most vulnerable
Americans
there is no popular call for this policy
that's why the dod had to Ram it through
the bureaucracy and the policy in no way
improves the military's Readiness or
ability to fight our foes
but this policy does matter to liberals
abortion matters a lot to liberals
if you ever doubted that look no further
than this fight in which our nation's
top military leaders would rather keep
three branches of service without a
leader than agree to tone back the baby
killing just a little bit
there are
a few people in Washington DC who are
endangering National Security right now
and none of those people is Tommy
tuberville I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
there's a lot of big news we have to get
to the that mother effort isn't real
girl from the airplane has issued an
apology we will go through every crucial
detail of that apology and then is there
anything else oh yeah there's this
little tiny bit of news they indicted
Trump again it's it's Groundhog Day
General Francisco Franco is still dead
and the libs have indicted Trump again
this one's a little different this one
is not at the federal level this is not
overdranuary 6th the worst in the
history of the world this is not over an
in-kind campaign contribution from some
tabloid story in New York this is over a
phone call that Trump had after the
Democrats rigged the election and he
called Georgia and he said hey what's
going on in Georgia where are the votes
uh that phone call now has gotten him
and his lawyers and all sorts of people
indicted the other big difference
between this indictment and the other
seven thousand indictments that they've
thrown at him before is that in this
case the authorities are promising to
take a mug shot
We are following our part our our normal
practices and so it doesn't matter your
status we we got mugshots ready for you
look at that little smirk that little
smirk on the Gestapo there at the end oh
I don't know it doesn't matter we're
going to take a mug shot this time yeah
and we're going to get you Trump now of
course
Trump is going to be thrilled by this
as he well he should be if the Liberals
are going to upend the American
political order if they're going to
upend
centuries of tradition and if they're
going to now criminalize politics which
is effectively what they're doing then
go big or go home
then I don't want them to be able to
weasel out of it and pretend they didn't
no no if you're going to arrest the
leader of the opposition and a former
president of the United States
then take that mug shot and make him a
political martyr which is what they're
going to do
uh hard to see how Trump
totally gets out of this now the reason
being that even if even if Trump becomes
president
I guess he could pardon himself
but he could only pardon himself at the
federal level right I get I think
I don't I don't think he could pardon
himself if he's convicted on state
charges we're in completely Uncharted
Territory here so we're kind of making
things up a little bit as we go along
now that the Democrats have decided that
we're going to descend into a tin pot
dictatorship a Banana Republic
but it's hard to see now that the
Democrats have brought Donald Trump on
at my last count seven billion charges
it's hard to see how they don't get them
on at least one especially in these
hostile places you can see you just you
look into the eyes of these liberals I
don't mean to be too hard on that cop
there because he's obviously just
following political orders and the
politicians are very clear that the
Democrats have decided they're going to
throw Trump in prison for the rest of
his life you look into their eyes you
just see fire burning there because the
eyes are the window to the soul and the
windows or the windows to your house
which when you want to replace them
you've got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text Knowles to 200
300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before for many it's not something
that they want to do rather it's
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing windows in your home
because it's too expensive I've got
great news you can now get a free
in-home window consultation and a free
price quote from Renewal by Anderson
Renewal by Anderson's signature service
is committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Andersen is offering a free in-home
or virtual consultation on top quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for a year text nulls kwles to
200 300 for your free consultation to
save 375 off every window and 750 off
every door
these savings will not last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Knowles
Kennedy Valley Esther 200 300 that's
Knowles to 200 300 texting and privacy
policy in terms and conditions posted at
textplan.us.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to window
appointmentnow.com for full offer
details this is not a bright moment for
Western political leadership
this is not not just in the United
States really for any
Western aligned country and especially
in military leadership you've got these
liberals at the Pentagon basically
shutting down the top command in order
to Ram through a radical and fantaside
policy and then
in the American colony in the Imperial
War were fighting overseas in Ukraine
you you see
well I'm going to let you see it for I'm
not allowed to do this this segment on
YouTube so if you want this segment
you've got to come to daily wire Plus or
to the RSS feed or to Twitter at mnol's
show I
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna introduce
it this way the Ukraine spokesman
spokesman
who is
not exactly
how that spokesman would appear and that
spokesman is exactly as you would expect
if Hollywood were writing this as a
movie and this spokesman has a message
for Vladimir Putin
[Music]
ad looks for the White House
in the unresponsiveness of this
Administration
a White House spokesman Karine
Jean-Pierre who I'm pleased to say is
the sex that she presents herself as
over at the White House
have finally addressed the horrific
wildfires in Hawaii President Biden was
approached on the beach asked to give a
comment about this
and you've got a rising death toll Mass
Devastation in Maui and Biden says no
comment no I'm too busy I'm too busy
thinking about Ukraine or I'm too busy
thinking about the blood dripping from
Dracula's mouth in in Moscow or whatever
so no I'm not going to care about my own
American citizens finally Korean
Champion addresses it she just gets some
details wrong
senator harino who I said the president
spoke to just last night he thanked the
president for the immediate support of
federal agencies have delivered for
residents of Hawaii
senator harino
Senator harino if you've never heard of
her
um or him I guess Korean Champion
actually misgenders for actually
misgenders the The Senator Senator
harino is a woman and her name's not
harino it's hirono and she's not even
just a minor back bench Senator she's a
senator who's on TV all the time she
never stops flapping her gums and she's
not even a republican where perhaps the
president might be forgiven or the White
House spokesman might be forgiven for
getting the name wrong if it's a member
of the opposition party Senator Maisie
hirono is one of the outspoken most
outspoken members of the president's own
party
not a great look
because the president is already being
criticized for not caring at all about
the devastation in Hawaii
and so the White House comes out and
says what are you talking about we care
a lot we are very concerned about Hawaii
and Senator harino harano haripi
whatever anyway what he's a dude oh it's
a chick okay yeah whatever we're really
focused though on what's going on in
Hawaii we don't even know the name of
the U.S senator from that place in our
own party but or the sex of that person
but hey we
we're on it you can count on us all
right now I got to get back on the phone
with the Kazakh oligarch so we can get a
few more
a few more tens of millions of dollars
for the big guy thank you very much
focused on the important things speaking
of
unfortunate videos of prominent women we
now finally will get to the story that
we teased a little bit yesterday I
wanted to make sure we had enough time
to get into it because it's it's
dominated the national discourse this of
course would be the that mother effort
isn't real lady from the airplane who
stood up
and and insisted that there was a mother
effort in the back of the airplane who
was not real and she said that the rest
of the passengers were free to stay on
the airplane and die with the unreal
person but she was going to leave the
airplane then she disappeared which I
felt was good for her and would have
been much better for her had she
remained Anonymous but the internet
figured out who she was somehow and now
this woman
is issuing an apology
hi everyone it's me
Tiffany Gomez probably better known as
the crazy plain lady which is completely
warranted
as you know I
have been unwilling to speak on the
viral video but can we just pause it
this woman looks nothing like the woman
from the video
she looks nothing like her she has a
different hair color sure even her face
looks different I'm not saying it's a
different person or Invasion of the Body
Snatchers or something but
I'm saying it because had this woman
just gone about her daily life
no one would have recognized her
I don't know she she darkened her hair a
little bit I'm sure she went through a
tough time after that video went viral
but she's deciding for some reason to
make a big public spectacle of herself
again this time I think probably more
ill-advisedly than the first time
time
first and foremost I
to
take full accountability for my actions
they were completely unacceptable
distressed or not I should have been I
should have been in control of my
emotions and no that was not the case
my use of profanity was completely
unnecessary
and I want to apologize to everyone on
that plane especially those that had
children aboard
can imagine going through that and
trying to explain to your kid what in
the world just happened
so she goes on and on this apology goes
on for something like two minutes
and I guess it's nice that she
is apologizing for using naughty
language around the kids even in our
culture where kids hear this all the
time I guess that's the appropriate
thing to do but beyond that
why apologize
what happened
did did she have a psychotic episode
well then she has no reason to apologize
she she wasn't in control of herself and
I don't think through Vice or something
like that she just
went a little bit nuts for a moment is
it because she was
on some kind of substance or something I
don't know she doesn't mention that here
is it because
why apologize this is a phenomenon that
has taken over the West in in our social
media age Jeremy has has called out this
weird phenomenon for a long time Jeremy
has called for the end of public
Apologies by private persons public
figures politicians
heads of Corporations maybe they can
make apology public apologies why This
Woman's not a public figure
if she wants to apologize she can
apologize to the airline she can write a
note to them or something have the
airline forward it out to the passengers
on the plane but what she doesn't owe me
an apology she doesn't owe you an
apology
why does everybody think that every
single little action every impulse has
to be public now probably comes from a
great place
Right comes from a good intention she's
trying to do the right thing so I'm
really not knocking her or criticizing
her but I'm giving a warning to
everybody else you don't owe the public
an apology for your private actions most
of the time
the only people she has an apology to or
the airplane and maybe the people on
that plane she doesn't owe one to the
entire internet we don't need to make
our every aspect of our lives at every
level of community an international
phenomenon we don't
we don't need to broadcast every single
thing to the world
though I I suppose because of Technology
because of the growth of Technology such
that we can transport messages across
the world instantly and because of the
advance of liberal ideology which which
erodes communities the most basic
political Community the family and local
community and National borders and
everything because of the simultaneous
advance of those two phenomena now
we've lost all perspective of community
everything's Global and and every every
single message is a message to the world
intended to go viral and it does go
viral it's it is like a virus it is an
epidemic of of
publicity of we don't need to be so
transparent we don't need to we can
things can be private or relatively
private as we lose the sense of the
proper community
which comes through the abolition of the
family and borders and the eradication
of federalism decisions being made at a
more local level as we lose that the
political order gets entirely wonky such
that we've now got Americans as the
military spokesman in Ukraine such that
we've now got massive foreign influence
in the United States elections we've got
we've got uh now the criminalization
even of politics at the whims of a mob
not good stuff
now when when your economic order is in
the same sort of disarray that our
political order is you're probably going
to want to check out American financing
right now go to
americanfinancing.net if you are like
most Americans you are struggling to
make ends meet and by the time you pay
the bills fill up your car and grocery
shop there's almost nothing left
everything is more expensive and most of
you are paying these bills with a credit
card Consumer Debt Rose over one
trillion dollars in the last year which
is the biggest increase in 20 years if
you're a homeowner there's a way out you
need to call my friends at American
financing they will put together a plan
to pay off that high interest credit
card debt and create meaningful savings
for you every month they're saving
people up to one thousand dollars a
month and closing in as fast as 10 days
don't wait get yourself into a better
position call their salary-based
mortgage consultants today and see how
much you can save 25 years of experience
and 7 000 glowing Google reviews speak
volumes about their ability to save
homeowners money it costs nothing to get
started and if you start today you could
delay two mortgage payments giving you
greater savings up front call American
financing today at
866-721-30300 that's
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net that's
americanfinancing.net
speaking of apologies there are calls
for apology from Skittles now Skittles
has a new package is these are for I
guess white Skittles
but it's a white Skittle bag with white
colored Skittles it looks like or a
sketched in pencil
and a nice big rainbow then a lot of
eccentric looking people and then little
statements
Joy is resistance
this is a liberal slogan Joy is
resistance they've got a little UFO
saucer thing because don't forget UFOs
are angels and demons for liberals so
they got all the UFO stuff little
Smileys little hearts and then this
phrase
[Music]
now enough about sexual revolutionary
politics let's turn to black
revolutionary politics there is a New
York city councilman Charles Barron
bragging
about losing white constituents
to be able to come before you and say I
actually lost white population in my
community
I lost them they left
I left I didn't ask him why they left
so if you see one or two or three or
four or five whites in my neighborhood
they're passing through
but that's on a serious note we got 13
000 black elected officials in this
country we've had Mayors we've had
Governors we have City Council Members
we need to get radical
oh we uh we have so many fewer white
people in this neighborhood I hate them
I hate those whites and I want to drive
them out I'm so happy they're not here
anymore and if you do see a white man in
my neighborhood just know he's just a
tourist he's just coming but if he stays
here too long we're going to chase him
out I hate white people now seriously on
a serious note I really hate white
people
and I don't want them to have any power
or representation anywhere I hate them
okay but no look enough joking enough
enough of the yucks around here okay we
gotta get serious and I seriously hate
white people
how many times does he need to tell you
what what shall we say about this I know
what I'm supposed to say I know what I
a conservative political commentator
who has a show and a platform I am
supposed to say pull my microphone here
could you imagine
could you even imagine if the shoe were
on the other foot and he were he were a
white man and he said that about black
because you even imagine
the double standard
could you imagine
keep imagining it okay that's what I'm
supposed to say
uh I don't want to say that because
that's extremely banal and obvious and
is going to be the Epitaph on the
gravestone of conservatism could you
imagine if the situation were reversed
that would be so crazy unimaginable
my takeaway from these comments and
similar comments that we've seen from
left-wing politicians in recent years is
when people call you a racist
it is never a sincere or meaningful
attack it never
if it ever was sincere or meaningful it
is not anymore it's not real
white people are basically the only
group that you can legally discriminate
against the Asians get lumped in a
little bit too
socially white people are the only group
that you are permitted to and actually
encouraged to insult and mock white
people are the only group whose decline
I'm not even just saying decline in
power or prominence I mean decline in
numbers in existence is the sort of
thing that will be celebrated
by the liberal media
it's not a real art when people call you
a racist all that means is I don't like
you you're bad and I want you to shut up
so just don't take it seriously this is
my only takeaway the only reason I even
bring up the story My takeaway for
conservatives and not even just for
white conservatives because you know if
you're a black conservative if you're a
Hispanic conservative if you're an Asian
conservative any color of conservative
you will be called a racist you will be
called a white supremacist no matter the
color of your skin no matter your racial
background Larry Elder is the black face
of white supremacy Candace Owens she's
basically a klansman at this point
according to the liberal media so it's
for everybody especially for white
people but it's for
anyone of any political any any literal
stripe any literal color uh who happens
to be heterodox in the modern liberal
establishment
don't take it seriously a liberal calls
you a racist you say oh cool
great awesome sure whatever that's it
it's a meaningless word that you're
calling okay no but you're us you're an
alt-right white supremacist racist super
Nazi cool oh cool man that's awesome wow
great can I get like a patch to put on
my jacket you know like a Letterman's
Patcher says that can I put that in my
Twitter bio
because it doesn't mean anything if
Charles Baron says this in New York City
gets away with it and this has been
going on for decades and decades
remember Professor was at Leonard
Jeffries Lionel Jeffries the one who
said that black people are the good
people of the sun white people are the
ice people without Souls this stuff is
repeated by celebrities even today Nick
Cannon repeated this stuff recently and
Professor jeffries's nephew Hakeem
Jeffries is now the Democrat leader in
the House of Representatives
it's just a joke
okay
you're a racist okay
I don't I I can't even deny it because I
don't even know what it means anymore
because the word doesn't have any
meaning anymore other than your bad
you're a baddie you're a baddie okay
speaking of black leaders
we talked about this letter that David
Garrow the biographer who's who's worked
on Barack Obama
and he's not just a biographer like he's
doing a hit piece on Obama or something
this is a guy he won the Pulitzer Prize
for biography in 1987 this is a very
serious liberal biographer and he's
writing this this biography of Obama he
says Obama's Memoir dreams for my father
is a work of fiction I know it Obama
knows it Obama knows that I know know it
when when David Guerra met with Obama in
the Oval Office Obama kind of taunted
him about the details of his life he
wouldn't show him and then this guy
found a letter
that Obama had written to uh to his
girlfriend at the time is back in 1982
and part of it was redacted by the
girlfriend and Guerra said well why why
is this redacted and she said it deals
with homosexuality
that's all we know well now we have the
unredacted letter
here is what Obama said
about his uh sexual orientation
in regard to homosexuality I must say
that I believe this is an attempt to
remove oneself from the present a
refusal perhaps to perpetuate the
endless farce of Earthly life
you see I make love to men daily but in
the imagination
now this I'm not just going to make fun
of Obama or try to gossip about him or
anything like that this is a profound
statement it's written Like A pompous
young young man would write but Obama
was only 21 years old at the time and he
was a pretty clever obviously ambitious
kid so not surprised that he would write
in that style
says in regard to homosexuality I must
say that I believe this is an attempt to
remove oneself from the present a
refusal perhaps to perpetuate the
endless farce of Earthly life now of
course I don't think Earthly life is a
farce
this is a very cynical atheist way of
talking it's a farce this hellish facade
of the world that we're talking about I
know I think the world is full of
meaning of course and that it doesn't
it's not a farce at all it's a happy
comedy like Dante would talk about but
he says homosexuality is a way to remove
oneself from
the process of generation that's true
that's obviously true and he says I make
love to men daily but in my imagination
so he's saying I have homosexual desires
but I don't carry them out and I I was
saying a couple of weeks ago
I think that social conservatives are a
little too harsh here
because a lot of them want to kind of
make fun of Obama for for appearing to
be a little bit light in the loafers but
what he's saying is I have homosexual
desires and I'm suppressing them
and I think what
what's he supposed to do isn't that good
isn't that what the social conservatives
want
social conservatives who don't have this
problem that Obama has it's very easy
for us to say well haha you know he he
he's fantasizing about men
but imagine if you were like him and you
had these homosexual desires today you
would just be told well you got to carry
that out but Obama's saying no I do want
to be even if it's a it seems like a
silly farce I do want to participate in
the process of creating life I do want a
wife I do want a family I do what he
probably obviously had political
Ambitions I do want to pursue my
political Ambitions and so I'm going to
subordinate my my sexual desires to that
isn't that shouldn't we as social
conservatives have a little bit of Grace
for people like Obama who maybe have you
know slightly eccentric sexual desires
and say oh well he all right he's doing
basically the thing that he wants to do
now the letter gets even crazier
because Barack Obama doesn't just say
that he's got these homosexual desires
He suggests that he's a little bit
has that for a tease when Dr Jordan B
Peterson made the decision to join daily
wire plus it was a major win for those
who championed Free Speech an
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled output
his contributions have set new standards
and remained unmatched by any other
platform daily wire plus now has a vast
array of exclusive Jordan Peterson
content offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created
thought-provoking works that reshape
your perspective on life includes vision
and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men Additionally you can
immerse yourself in discussions that
nurture your spiritual side like logos
and literacy and Jordan's groundbreaking
series on the book of Exodus I have not
even mentioned his Beyond order lecture
series or his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts plus there's even
more new exclusive content on the
horizon this is only the beginning by
becoming a daily wire plus member you
will embark on an unforgettable
experience that will fuel your thirst
for knowledge and Inspire personal
growth like never before go to daily
wire.com subscribe to become a member
today
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Jonathan Perez 2h23 who says it's not
enough that Michael is such a tease now
he's teasing his teases I can't even
right now wow how providential that that
comment came up just after I mentioned a
little tease
here's what Obama said about his
gender identity
my mind is androgynous to a great extent
and I hope to make it more so until I
can think in terms of people not women
as opposed to men but in returning to
the body I see that I have been made a
man and physically in life I choose to
accept that contingency
I love I love that expression I give
Obama a lot of credit I have greater
respect for Obama's intellect and and
willpower actually
after reading that than I did before and
I know all the other conservatives are
going to make fun of him and call them a
FANUC or whatever but
this is really
this was commonplace thinking 20 years
ago 30 years ago now it's pretty rare
this is my mind is androgynous into blah
blah blah okay is a 21 year old pompous
kid and he's a liberal so he's saying oh
I'm so expansive nothing no definition
can contain me man I'm just I'm like a
little I'm a woman in the morning a man
in the afternoon I don't want to think
in terms of these small categories man
I'm so much bigger than that you know
okay so he's just talking like every
pompous college junior you've ever met
who is a liberal with Notions of
grandeur uh but then what do you say he
goes
but in returning to the body
my mind feels androgynous mind meaning
not a physical thing but a metaphysical
thing right the mind is not the brain
the mind is closer to the soul that's
what we would say so he says my soul
feels
male and female
but in returning to the body I see I've
been made a man and physically in life I
choose to accept that contingency
this is very based
this is downright to Mystic he's saying
my soul is not gendered Thomas Aquinas
would say the soul is not gendered but
the body
is sexed sex derives from the body and
applies to the whole individual the
whole person because we're Body and Soul
inextricably linked on Earth and he says
so I see that I'm a man and I choose to
accept that contingency which is very
base because not only is he saying I
will not be
he's also saying I won't act on my
homosexual desires
because I am a man and being a man
implies not merely accepting the
biological facts of our body but but
also accepting the T loss of our body
the the the purpose of our body what our
body is for
this is this is far right wing social
conservative
traditional catholic uh teaching right
here coming out of Barack Obama
what does that tell you does it tell you
that Barack Obama's a secret
conservative it doesn't
what it tells you is just how radically
to the left the culture has gone in the
last 40 years this was written in 1982
and everybody even the Liberals
understood oh yeah I've got a body that
implies that I obviously can't pretend
to be the opposite sex and it also
implies that I'm supposed to do certain
things with my body that that the
highest and only moral Maxim is not
simply if it feels good do it even
Barack Obama was saying that he may have
changed his view somewhere down the line
but that is pretty pretty based
next time someone tells you that you're
you're a social conservative and and
your views are fascistic and far right
what you tell them you tell them that
you have the same views on sex and
gender that Barack Obama had in 1982
while he was writing about his fantasies
of sleeping with men
which brings us to this question
ha
how did the culture move so left so fast
a lot of it was the sexual Revolution I
I don't want to harp on the weird sex
stuff too much I like to talk about you
know I don't know the indictments the
political order the wars overseas
immigration trade like all these
important issues but the sex stuff comes
up a fair bit because it's such a huge
motivating factor in human nature and
because when the limits of behavior have
been eroded
by say an act of sexual Revolution it it
becomes an even more pronounced driver
and it's because it's the the instrument
by which the libs have taken over a lot
of the culture and one way they've done
it one way to explain the huge advance
of degeneracy in recent decades is
pornography the ubiquity of Internet
pornography it's just something we've
never seen before ever in the history of
human life
now it's virtually everywhere and people
say
conservatives such as I would say we
should heavily regulate it if we can't
ban it entirely we should heavily
regulate it and you've got liberals and
some Libertarians saying
well no we can't we can't regulate it we
need the internet to be free man let
people watch whatever degraded filth
they want to watch you know it's free
country man whatever even though it's
even by the letter of the law today this
stuff is already illegal because it
violates obscenity laws it's just
liberal judges have changed the
standards for obscenity so how would you
regulate it people say well give me a
concrete action how would you regulate
it here's how you would regulate it you
would require people to prove that they
are at least 18 when they access even
just the main porn site the one owned by
mindgeek which is the biggest porn
conglomer in the world PornHub you just
say okay in order to access this website
you have to prove that you're your age
now the the Libertarians will respond
and say so you want to give a porn
company every every ID in America or I
don't know 70 of IDs in America eighty
percent of ideas in America
my answer to that is no
if if you pass that regulation first of
all PornHub would just stop operating
because they know that preying on
children is crucial to the success of
their industry that's why they've pulled
out of Utah that's why they've pulled
out of several states that have passed
these age requirement laws they would
rather not do business in those States
than comply with an age check because
they they need to prey on kids but
but even if if it went through and
PornHub we're still operating PornHub
would not get all the ideas in America
because most people the vast majority of
people would be too ashamed to submit
their ID the moment you took anonymity
away from it most people other than the
most hardened perverts would stop
looking at it because the law is not
merely shaped by the culture as the
Libertarians say
there's some truth to that of course but
the law is also a teacher and also
shapes culture and if you pass that
simple kind of Regulation
the the effect of that I think Americans
still have enough shame
that that would greatly reduce
the Indulgence in advice and it would
greatly greatly reduce the presence of
all sorts of social pathologies that
we're not allowed to talk about on
YouTube
here's a little tease for tomorrow
speaking of bad behavior did you know
that almost one in five Americans are
now puffing the devil's lettuce
uh no listen they're going to be a lot
of people watching listening to the show
right now who like to have a little
little hit on the sin spinach
[Music]
it's not good it's not good
it's not good we'll talk about it
tomorrow the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss it because
today is they've informed me I'm not
allowed to say the name of the member
segment today it's Tuesday we have you
know music Monday woke Wednesday we have
something Tuesday but I'm not allowed to
say the name of the day on
YouTube so I'll have to use a euphemism
so I could I thought if I took out the T
I could say it's it's eunuch use day
is that I think you get what I'm getting
at become a member now use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]